today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block get that
hitter alright today's episode is
brought to you by the ridge the ridge is
a minimalist front pocket wallet that
helps you really your everyday carry
what's in your carry have you thought
about that which you got a little one of
them small jars of Olives which you got
a couple of uh you know domestic dispute
tickets which you got pissing in public
citation would as part of your everyday
carry credit cards condoms you know
different stuff all kind of stuff
recipes hotel keys you know small items
that can fit in a wallet but aren't you
sick of that well now the ridge is a
minimal front pocket wall at this design
to let you ditch your bulky rear little
butt hump look at that thing Oh what
does that guy have is that a tumor no
that's a bulky wallet the ridge wallet
is slim RFID blocking and lifetime
guaranteed so that means if you die dude
you're you can't get a new one but if
you don't die you can get a new one if
something happens to the one you have
it's the last wallet you'll ever buy I'm
rocking my front pocket son no more
reaching into my ass to get something
that's insane
it comes in titanium carbon fiber and
aluminum and polycarbonate and they also
have dope-ass Ridge backpacks in other
Ridge accoutrements so Ridge up go to
Ridge wallet comm slash Theo the link
will be below
that's Ridge wallet comm slash Theo and
use the promo code Theo for 10% off you
know I once stood shirtless with Dan the
man Cummings overlooking the African
Serengeti and I asked him a question
about something or other and he talked
for about an hour about it Chad had
chatted and I left that conversation
feeling fulfilled to the max about
whatever I'd asked him about and I like
to think that Dan turned that African
moment into today what is a juggernaut
podcast but the truth is that he always
had it in him if the internet had a
Magellan that man Gellin is the human
squirrel Dan Cummins his podcasts times
suck takes you on a weekly delve beneath
the layers thoroughly exploring and
explaining a single listener suggested
topic each Monday in his own irreverent
and entertaining style everything from
menthol cigarettes bees with autism
historical events Loch Ness mice
paranormal encounters conspiracy
theories cryptozoology and more nothing
is off-limits from big Dan and that time
suck nothing not even your stepmom if
it's interesting it's time suckable so
have some fun and learn something new
with time suck each and every week
you'll love dan just as much as I did in
Africa and in other countries but just
as friends it's time you know as much as
you can about things
checkout time suck podcast
[Applause]
[Music]
come on now come with me here I'm here
are you come on yeah yeah and my mom is
somewhere else
found it I'll patch up where it's been
that's a thing up brainwork
[Music]
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself allow me oh I'll
sit and tell you the story
[Music]
and you light on me I'll find that song
and I will sing it just for you
thank you guys so much for for being
here it is is who knows when it is man
its existence that's what it is that's
when it is that is a song called shine
and the band is called Bishop gun
Bishop gun and they are a new band and
you can check them out to other links to
their iTunes and that and and YouTube
and stuff but and they have that new
single out and I have a relationship to
this band when I was in college and out
of high school my my best friend
actually had a his brother-in-law owned
a farm in up in Natchez Mississippi and
actually it was it was right along the
Mississippi River the farm was but the
family lived in Natchez our Natchez as
some people say it and Natchez is just
this dirty little sultry taffy box just
nestled in an elbow crook of the
Mississippi River up there and it's just
got so many skeletons in his closet you
could [ __ ] smell the bone marrow from
200 miles outside of town but it's uh I
would go up there in the summers and I
would stay with this family and and I
would work on their phone and I would do
farm stuff you know I'd move seed I'd
fertilize I'd chew tobacco I'd stand
around and think about the weather we
would look you would shoot shoot it
snakes after lunch we would he eat
really big tomatoes what else would we
do my painted I [ __ ] ruined a bunch
of [ __ ] I broke a truck
I lost probably about $2,000 with the
tools into a huge
like kind of a huge little pond
yeah just did it all you know young work
and the man had a family and he had a
wife and three children and I got to
know the family well over the years and
and the man died
my buddy died his name was Richard
Sharpe and he passed away he suffered
from addiction and I don't think I'm you
know letting ghosts out of his lamp I
think that's okay but he was a good
friend of mine and he was somebody that
I admired you know he was more of a
mentor in a way but but he had three
sons and one of them now has a band and
and he's the drummer in this band called
Bishop Gunn and that is um that's their
single right there that just came out
and that song is called shine
and let myself all my shine
on it baby so so anyway if you want to
check that out you can but um but I'm
just so proud of the young fella and and
I know his father would be very proud of
him as well and is wherever he is thank
you guys for being here with me man it
is it's Monday is April 30th and and
this is it we are here we are here again
and in the timeline of existence in the
year 2018 out here in the universe and
and I uh what if I've been doing minute
I um I went to to Maui I went to Maui
and got some of that sunshine dude I
don't have you ever been to Hawaii or
Maui or any it is you know but first of
all everybody goes to bed at like 9:00
o'clock at night so you wake up at
[ __ ] 6:30 in the morning and you're
fresh like you were like it's like
you're a regular person I went to bed at
9 o'clock at night two nights in a row
and I hadn't done that since since
probably junior high school when was the
last time you went to bed at 9:00
o'clock no I go to bed at 1:00 o'clock
after masturbating and after laying
there in my own shame that is more my
pattern so to go to bed at night I mean
if anybody nobody's awake past 9:00
o'clock on the whole island like you
don't I mean unless they're burglars and
it's just burglars just talking other
burglars I guess outside because nobody
else natural regular humans non burglars
or awake and man it's just relaxing it
was just relaxing man got to spend some
time over there you know with this
little gal you know I'm going to spend a
little bit of time here and there and
and what I'll do caught some sunshine
and do you get out in the ocean out
there and it's just that salty it's like
a big [ __ ] salty dog
looking at your whole body I mean it's
just the ocean is just a big just a big
damp salty tongue just wandering around
up and all your crevices you know I'm
just washing you and [ __ ] just I mean
you get that salt water into your brain
and it just takes away all of the dirty
thoughts and all of the the dark arts
that have just been coagulating in your
sound holes when it gets you know when
that water gets in here ears and and you
got the Sun man when you fit when the
Sun hits you there you can just feel the
Lord just touching your titties with his
with his UV arms and it is I mean it was
awesome if you have not been because I
always thought Hawaii man [ __ ] them you
know it's people out there you know
molesting fish and you know you know
eating you know fresh pineapple but
outside of that just molesting fish and
you know and hide and you know I'm
hiding in like a place that's like a
fake Vietnam you know kind of like a
fancy Vietnam but without all the action
but the truth is you get over there
under that island or any of them I think
and but Maui is where I was and you just
oh man you you I just felt I felt
peaceful I felt peaceful and then go get
a coffee in the morning I ain't man I
had a piece of fish over there I had
some I don't know what it was tuna some
tuna sashimi and sashimi that [ __ ] is
straight-up ninja style it's like a
ninja distrain up on a you know maybe a
fish was waiting at the bank or
something waiting in line and then the
ninja just came in and just yeah and
next thing you know you got nine little
just grams of sashimi and some people
you know it's just fresh cut little
chunks dude this fish was so fresh dude
I mean they had you could see other fish
like we were sitting by this restaurant
you know looking out on the water there
other fish still looking for this fish
like he just left the group like he just
swam off and next thing he noticed chef
was out there on a cigarette break
snatch skin and then BAM sashimi and I
put a chunk in my jaw and then eat the
rest some people they get their sashimi
they have it piece at a time piece at a
time piece at a time
piece at a time [ __ ] that bro I ain't no
worse dude when it come to putting down
fresh fish son man my hands I get going
fast on that [ __ ] you know I get out
there boy I got that carpal tunnel you
feel me
cuz I got that you know like I do that
no I you know I [ __ ] put you know I
feel that fish up and I put a chunk in
my jaw put two hits of that sashimi in
my jaw and then I have the rest natural
face-first but man it was beautiful and
I never thought why you know you always
hear about awhile but I'm like oh
everybody likes her well you know it's
everybody everybody something everybody
does but man Maui is where it's at if
you want to go feel something and if you
want to wake up a refreshed
damn I felt like sashimi in the morning
I just felt refreshed and so that was a
beautiful thing that was awesome um what
else is going on they had you know they
had this I saw this news thing where
they were making fun at the White House
dinner or whatever they're making fun of
the Sarah Huckabee Sanders you know the
correspondents lady and some of this
[ __ ] but like are we supposed to where
we are supposed to make fun of women
we're not supposed to make fun of women
like what's okay because I'm it's like
Melissa just makes me mad
you know and I don't know if it makes me
mad it's like it's all just situational
based are we really trying to move
forward as a group of people you know I
look at that lady I don't I don't care
what political party she's with but I
look at the lady she seems you know you
know she's kind of a little bit of she
might be a little homely looking
but she you know I look at her and be
like I'm just happy you know I'm excited
for a woman has this job it's exciting
right that's what I feel like I'm you
know as progressed you know feeling
progressively that's what I'm supposed
to think I'm supportive that you know a
woman is the face of politics or a face
of you know things people are talking
about or you know that's exciting right
but then you have other women Bosch it's
just what are we doing are we moving
forward it's just pick and choose it's
only move forward when you want to move
forward you know it's just like I don't
know that [ __ ] just makes me upset
because I look at that lady and I say
look I'm happy for this lady you know
it's nice to see a regular looking lady
out there you know Sheena you know she
know she in an eleven she ain't a
Victoria's Secret model she more of like
a Victor loudmouth model you know but
she's still out there she's still being
brave and being you know getting in
front of reporters get in front of the
news and saying her piece and so I just
don't understand sometimes it's like
you'll you know the media will gripe and
everything if if you point to you know
you say anything about some women but
other women it's totally okay I just
don't get it are we supporting women or
we're not supporting women are we
supporting people are not supporting
people it's only beautiful people that
you know that lady has to be an 11 or a
10 for us to you know for the White
House Correspondents Dinner to be nice
to her
[ __ ] that you know I'm trying to be nice
and I'm trying to be nice son you're
gonna sit here judge how people look but
then say don't judge how women look what
are we doing I'm sorry miss stuff just
makes me mad it just makes me mad
because it's not let's just be fair if
we finally make fun of her make fun of
them make fun of also um Barbara Bush
make fun of Michelle Obama make fun of
you know Chrissy tagging everybody but
you're gonna go pick on a lady that's
not that attractive
just because you just made some nice
[ __ ] just makes you mad what do we
doing you know onward bro so I'm over it
now but sometimes I gotta voice some of
that stuff dude because this [ __ ] just
gets me crispy but I'm gonna try to
uncritically came in I'm gonna tell you
this right now for this episode I had a
call you know we do follow-ups on this
show where we'll have people reach out
about things that are going on and then
you know a month later or two months
later we call a follow up with them and
just kind of you know check in and I did
a follow up with trick lung Mickey and
he you know he's a young man that has
cystic fibrosis and he you know he's
been on the transplant list for lungs
and I even thought I first thing I was
like let's get some lungs through the
show let's get him some lungs you know
I'll break him off a [ __ ] bag
you know I'll break him off a [ __ ]
you know one of these hot air sacks I'm
riding on but apparently somebody has to
die for you to get their lungs and it
has to be a match you can't donate lungs
to somebody or along so anyhow um you
know and long story short you know
Mickey I met up with him in Tacoma he
was gonna do some stand-up comedy but
then he got really sick and he's been in
ICU but anyway we're gonna do a
follow-up call with him a little bit
later on this episode and and so I was
just gonna make that a follow-up call
that I was going to do today but that
ends up being a some of the episode
later man it because it was it was just
it was awesome it was an awesome
experience there's an awesome call and
so in the meantime for now and then I'm
just gonna be just just you know
carrying on the regular episode but that
follow-up call with him turned into the
rest of the episode and so if things
seem a little out of place today just
just let them just let it be known
that's the way things are that's just
the way that things are what else is
going on with me um then I'm feeling
pretty good today
you know it's Jang China I'm struggling
with these fighting these cigarettes and
I you know these cigarettes man you get
it down
I mean these cigarettes man what did
they put in there that [ __ ] got me you
know around my mouth I mean the back of
my tongue will water a little bit
sometime wanting my cigarette around
about maybe 10:30 at night and I've been
doing good and I hadn't no cigarettes in
the daytime and not having me one
cigarette late at night you know kind of
like a step daddy and but I'd love to
get fully off of him and here's why
because for one I've been smoking them
I'm [ __ ] 38 dude I'm gonna dolt male
so you know I was out there 15 hiding
under the bleachers smoking them you
know they used to have this girl uh big
Sydney this um I guess she was white I
don't know it was dark out but she um
she would always get under the bleachers
at the football games and take these
hits off these cigarettes and blow it
into her face and she would get [ __ ]
sick from it but she liked it you know
she liked uh I don't know I guess maybe
she had bulimia or wanting to have
believe me or something I don't know she
was thick even though it was dark out
you could see that she was you know
working with some space and you know she
was wearing belts she would wear a man's
belt and when you a child a female child
and you wearing a man's belt you know
you [ __ ] him packing you know you you
know you're we're on a lunch table
you know she wear a man's belt and also
she you know her mom dad was real
nearsighted so I think her mom couldn't
see really how big she was and so the
mom would just always be feeding her up
and just you know they'd had big meals I
remember a couple times her mom would
come by to school at lunch and they
would eat in the car her mom would make
a big spread and put her in the back of
the car and they'd sit over there and
eat eat over by the by the fence by the
chain-link fence and sometimes I'd sit
of air and had me a little box of runts
or candies and watch her and her mother
eat
Sallis berry steak and all of that in
the back of a aah what was that a
could've been a Crown Victoria but but
we used to blow cigarette smoke on her
under the bleachers and she would vomit
you know it was kind of this it wasn't
like a trick or a party trick or
anything but it was like something to do
but you know that's when I saw you know
I'd be I was puffing out there at a
young age and I wasn't buying cigarettes
but I would smoke them every now and
then you know I was that occasional
hitter you know so you wouldn't catch me
you know at the um you know over there
at the Citgo station or over at there
Phillips 76 or whatever you wouldn't
catch me out there at that Exxon marble
you know hitting them Winston's but if
somebody had when I bum that Winston and
then next thing you know I'm puffing out
and and most of my life has just been
like that I puffed out here and there
but then once I got sober quit party and
I got me you know I started to pick up a
little bit of extra cigarettes here and
there and now I was like about that best
I've been doing so anyway but timewise
that's one reason I need to quit I've
been doing it I've done it
the second reason for me is that if I
[ __ ] in here's the thing if I'm having a
tough moment instead of sometimes
dealing with whatever my tough moment
isn't figuring out what's actually going
on I'll go get that hitter you know I'll
go get that you know I'll go get it
I'll put that little you know that
little carcinogen kut'r stick in my
mouth and I'll take that hit you know
and I get them cigarettes so that's
another reason because the cigarettes
become my my they become what I go to
instead of going to okay let me solve or
try and think about what's going on or
feel what my feelings are right now so I
can [ __ ] expound on them and try and
get better instead I go get that hitter
and then and then I don't deal with my
feelings I deal with them by having a
cigarette and then the third thing in a
weird way is cigarettes become my god
they become my higher power because if
I'm having a tough moment and then
instead of going oh man I you know I
need to ask a higher power I need to ask
the universe or I need to ask my god
what's going on
or you know I asked him for some
guidance instead I'll get that hitter so
those are the three reasons why I
wouldn't like to quit but it's hard it
is harm and it got that [ __ ] gripping us
and they got that [ __ ]
gripping us what else oh the man up the
the I want to thank everybody man I want
to thank you if you're listening right
now be supportive go subscribe be a part
of this past weekend because you know we
need we need to we need it all and we
got a show now on that was on Comedy
Central it's just a pilot so they took a
pilot episode they broke it into a
couple of segments three segments and
all of them are out there so there are
three different episodes that are out
there they're each about like 12 minutes
long you can watch them on Facebook and
you can share them or you can watch them
on YouTube and you can share them but
here's the thing
go share them because they're based on
this podcast and they're all real calls
that came in to the podcast one of them
has Bobby Lee in it because his
girlfriend called in and but the other
ones are just called people that called
in to the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three and then
we responded to the calls and got those
people out and made real episodes that
you can now watch on Comedy Central it's
online but we're hoping to get to a TV
show so go out there and share it
comment tell them look this needs to be
a show because I don't know some of the
[ __ ] they be putting on television no
but I'm ready to be you know if we get
this past weekend out there and we're
gonna do some good stuff but man I was
sitting at home and uh and and then
somebody sent me the link and I'm like
wow man look what we did look what we
did I don't do this we got this is team
effort this team effort we meet up here
each week and we do this [ __ ] boy like a
couple of [ __ ] dirty stallions you
know like a couple of dirty horses that
come up here and just just press they
[ __ ] chests up against each other you
know and just not just put their dirty
knees up in each other's [ __ ] armpit
and that's how we do that but I'm
grateful so go check it out man up and
it's based on this past week and you can
see that this past weekend logo right in
the beginning and and who knows it's out
of my control if it becomes a TV show if
it doesn't become a TV show I don't care
I mean do I care a little bit I would
like for it to but that's out of my
control what's in my control is what we
already did I know what we did is good
you know I know we got a guy out there
on roller skates and everybody's you
know um there's one episode people are
puffing on that green you know hit
getting that [ __ ] DEP DEP that brocco
Lockheed up in their brain lungs
on that puff path and and I'm sitting
there to ice I don't know why they got
high now for me look man that doesn't
test my sobriety they want to get high
that's fine you know I'm good but we
still went out there and partying that
phone we got on roller skates and we
acted like we weren't on roller skates
and and it was a blast so check it out I
hope you enjoy it but thank you at the
same time thank you for being a part of
whatever we're doing here making things
happen
um just going on or been on my brain oh
I'm going skydiving this week so it's
kind of scary it has died in it so
that's kind of alarming I've been
thinking about that I still can't
believe that lady got [ __ ] sucked out
of an airplane
what can you imagine that unless the
person you're next to is so aggravating
bra and then their window breaks and
they get sucked out I would be like oh
[ __ ] you know somebody was snapchatting
that [ __ ] too like damn they having
trouble in 13b coffin coffin emoji you
know somebody's putting this [ __ ] that
can even that's crazy people die in now
and they want you to die a little slower
so they could put it on there snap
that's the world we are in that's the
world we are in what's real we don't
know we got to what's real
what's real man what's an illusion
what's a ghost what you got a lot of
these money ghosts out there things that
just show up to get your money they
don't want to leave you with anything a
lot of the [ __ ] and things you'd be
buying or selling or all of this cat
[ __ ] next thing you know you own two
[ __ ] $900 blenders and you lonely is
[ __ ] sitting outdoors with no
electricity and no fruits or anything to
make a smoothie that's the money ghosts
man what are you getting you're buying
something what are you getting what are
you getting that's what I'm asking
myself these days anybody that came from
Fighter and the kid they got a belt for
me finally the fighter in the kid
podcast if you don't listen to that
podcast man I'll tell you this I saw
Brendan Schaub this weekend and Brendan
Schaub seemed like um he seemed like a
UH like a rescue pitbull that kind of
got his act together if you ever seen
him he seemed like a pip but like a cut
like a Rottweiler something I went to
Community College but he um he's one of
the hosts over there and uh every time I
see that guy he met he makes me he just
joyous he's filled with joy you know God
just put a lot of joy in him and he
that's a natural blessing because I
don't know I don't I don't show up like
that every day
it's gotten better for me over time but
Brendan Schaub he shows up every day he
wakes up and he probably his mouth is
full and he has to spit up because he's
just full of joy and man that's a
beautiful place to be isn't it I'm
always envious of those people you know
I used to look at um I'm friends with
the the Miz the wrestler and he was
always so he was just full of just joy
every day and I was always like man how
does he what a lucky guy but I do notice
over time that um that I find that I do
get a little more joy I do notice that
when I start to shed these other skins
that are [ __ ] all they're doing is
weighing me down I think they're
protecting me but all they're doing is
weighing me down I do feel a little bit
or joy but yet at big girl we still blow
cigarette smoke on her and she would
vomit and I don't I guess in hindsight
she just wanted to probably you know
lose weight you knowing that was some
way that she found she could do it so
we'd be back there just huffing these
Winston's and you know just bust in
these you know lungs full of smoke on to
her and she would be you know Expo
expelling all this food and stuff she'd
been eating cuz her mom would show up in
that uh her mom would show up in that
car and they would sit in the backseat
and he eat plate meals together uh mom
have you know uh put them you know those
trays that you sit if you um or real
lays you put that tray um you know in
front of your chair or something or not
lazy but if you like to eat and watch TV
and I don't have that experience in my
life yet but I am looking forward to
that [ __ ] getting that lazy boy getting
that [ __ ] Miami tray right there so
you could just even if you doze off
forward you could just doze right into a
damn you know into a macaroni salad you
know just you could just doze or just
right into semi-sweet patate and uh and
anyway so you know I think she wanted
just vomit cuz her and her mama be
hitting me you know these six and seven
course meals just sitting there in the
back of his some of this yellow Crown
Vic and I don't know why they did that
[ __ ] man but that's people you know
that's people right there
I had a friend when I was growing up his
parents or somebody in his house who was
an adult gave him a [ __ ] a tattoo on
his back of a snake and this
[ __ ] was ten and he hated snakes
so you can't even imagine most of his
life probably just can you imagine the
fear you have hate and snakes and having
a snake on your back god damn the devil
the devil is alive we got some great
calls that came in we got some neat
stuff happening I'm looking for a venue
in Chicago I preach to everybody that's
reached out and shared about it I am
trying to make that happen
looks like we're gonna be adding a date
in rural Illinois coming up here
what else I'm gonna let you know right
now that I'll be at cluster fest in San
Francisco that's June 2nd and 3rd I'll
be at Cherokee Casino in West Siloam and
if it's not on the website call him and
tell him to put the tickets I feel you I
don't know why they're having me come
not selling tickets yet I'll be in
Calgary up there in Canada and that's
the 15th through the 7 15th and 16th of
June I'll be in Oxnard California and
that is July 6th through the 8th and
what else we got July 20th through the
22nd albeit good nights in Raleigh North
Carolina believe and what else we got
some other dates coming up they're going
to be happening September 14th and 15th
zany's in Nashville other dates will be
added soon for the comedy tour the dark
arts tour and the new websites up diovan
calm you can go there and check it out
we got them shirts we got the dark arts
dark art dark artist survivor shirts
there's there's some pans there's a
couple of new things in there and you
can go to the you can also go to the
this past weekend page there and there's
ways to submit if you want to submit a
video question you can do that if you
want to submit an audio you want to hit
the hotline or if you want to drop in a
text and reach out and be a part of
what's going on here on this past
weekend then we certainly welcome that I
want to thank all our patreon errs as
well I'll put a new youtube comedy clip
up called Thundercat about this boy that
grew up my neighborhood named Thundercat
Johnson and you could check that out as
well but I'm just so grateful man I'm
feeling some gratitude I want to thank
everybody that reached out after last
week's episode you know I just had to
have a moment where I just just showed
up and got real with what's going on in
my life you know what's going on with my
feeling because I'm runner I'll just run
around sometimes you get so busy running
around jumping on your phone watching TV
talking to a friend you know satiating
yourself with food sex you know a masty
doing that nasty you know Fritos
whatever you like barbeque drinking
condiments bruh we had this dude in our
neighborhood [ __ ] tall
Herbie and he would drink [ __ ]
condiments brah that dude take a take a
16-ounce bottle of hunts catch up to the
dome and leave that bang empty he'd
[ __ ] double up to just just double
fist and two things of French's mustard
straight down the gullet so you never
know what the Lord has in store for you
all right man let's get into some calls
here dude this episode's all over the
place but you have to stick around
because the call when I reach out to
Mickey man to [ __ ] huh it just brought
me back to where I needed to be today
here we go how he comes back again from
cracklin caught him oh we got an ally
from Scotland and this this me dizzy
this little vixen called in last week
and she got that that exciting um she
has that exciting accent you know she
got that accent sound like somebody that
might have died on the Titanic right
there and it's beautiful let me listen
again
it's how he going back again from
Brooklyn caught him I just wanted to say
I'm glad that I make you smile and my
comment from Alaska and I don't want to
be cheeky but I wanted to highlight some
things that have your fish tonight okay
she wants to highlight something she
noticed two times now so let's hear more
thank you for calling back alley there
seems to be a little bit of confusion on
your part
it was between Scottish and I there
could be I think yeah yeah there
definitely is I think homework so on the
roving truck episode you said that you
loved please honey thought that that was
Irish when guys got it okay so I like
the Pogues and they were Irish but
they're Scottish okay homeward I'm
getting Michael you said about the punks
what are in fact violence and not
Scottish okay so I haven't mixed up
again let me listen to you again here to
explain those things to me Ali thank you
for for helping me out here with this
because I'm obviously you know my brain
you know I've been some places but my
brain hasn't been all those same places
it was between Scottish and I oh my god
when you laugh I just want to I don't
even know what I want to do I just want
to just I just want to take over you
know I just want to enslave an African
continent I mean I just there's
something special about you know not in
a really way but it's enslaved part of
the world you know like you just yeah I
am I just want to watch that movie
butterfly effect have you seen that it's
with um James J Braddock when he fights
a banker it's um you've seen it it's
with Russell Crowe oh my god isn't good
let's hear more so on the rolling truck
episode you said that you loved please
honey thought that that was Irish when I
sculpted okay so you're saying something
I thought on Robin trained with Scottish
but it's actually Irish and I got I
can't hear exactly what you're saying
but it's [ __ ] just sounds so
beautiful but God dude it sound like
there's just a damn like just like a
million kids just you know just blowing
bubbles and smoking dope and just
running out of your face any into my
ears and it sounds good getting Michael
you said about the punks what are in
fact Irish and not Scottish hmm
so the Pogues are Irish huh yeah and
that Pogues I know for sure now so
they're not SCOTUS I'm gonna remember
that I appreciate that we'd be right the
folks here and they are definitely is
very very interesting eyes culture and I
do know my husband
hey she does have a husband it's
something you know what just happened to
me when she said that there was a pie on
my windowsill and the burglar just came
up and stole it
that's what happened inside of me more I
come yes I I forgot to mention her here
the trapar here as a university and full
time
works okay to sell so you know anything
what oh well thank you for calling he
sounds like a lucky man and I appreciate
you calling back alley and explaining to
me that I got some issues when it come
to Scotland
Scotland Ireland and I'm gonna figure
some of this stuff out and I'm gonna
come over there and do some shows
hopefully next year or maybe whenever
they'll let me you know I don't know
what all the legalities are or if I got
anything pending or something because
there's been I've had some issues at
some of these airports but thank you for
calling I love you and good day and
onward onward you know the Andrea Gail
it should have never sunk okay let's
take another call here here we go hey
Jack Chicago what's up Jack I'm trying
to find some places come there and
perform right here soon and I'll say
this to Mitchell true Biscay I think
he's gonna be the truth the truth Biscay
this year
I love the Bears I love what they do you
take risks homework over today Congrats
man 75 days will you coming up on 90
days and there's something beautiful
about hitting that 90 man and an ohm
word that's all I can tell you they're
more you know pills heroin cocaine
alcohol you name it dang he was getting
it all that's that ROYGBIV you know you
putting all the colors in your [ __ ]
soul bro more and I know you're sober
too just want to say thank you there you
know your stand-up and your podcast
helps me get through it
and you know thank you very much man and
also just wanted to ask what do you do
how do you stay
how do you stay clean well I appreciate
you call them in I'm not gonna go into
this too much because I've gone into it
before and really for me this call is
about you you know I'm happy here 75
days man I'm her you know because here's
the thing people are like ah
Theo talks about sober stuff all the
time and this and that look dude do I
want to be sober no no I don't want to
be so start right there I'm doing
something I don't want to do you know so
that's why it's
you know that's why this is a part of my
life all the time because I'm doing
something
imagine you have rollerskates on all the
time and you don't want to skate that's
where I'm at and everybody's like oh man
you uh you know you have a trouble
hanging out on one side of the kitchen
because the house is slanted
well [ __ ] yeah I do cuz I'm on skates
and I don't want to be on them but I
stay on them and that's what the journey
is you're doing something that you don't
really want to do and it starts to
reward you look man I don't know what
keeps me sober
but I know it doesn't and that's drugs
and that's alcohol because of drugs so
but hearing people and feeling people's
feelings man we're gonna get a call at
the end of this man if you want
something to keep you sober today wait
till you get to this last call in
today's episode for me it did it but
congratulations jack I'm happy for you
and and you call and tell me your 75
days that's that keeps me sober man
knowing that somebody else is out there
with the roller skates home and the
floors leaning and they don't want to be
skating but they stay in on the skate so
let's hear more and I don't know if I
always will be sober and I don't you
know I don't know but but right now I am
and there we go let's hear more no fee
oh this is matt from new england matt
from new england and that's almost
british straight up nobody ever talks
about that [ __ ] so Oh weird I work at a
drunk tank alright and I worked a third
drunk tank like what do you mean like
Dave and Buster's I don't even know what
that is let's hear more heard shift you
know the graveyard shift so I see the
craziest of the crazies
so basically last week and I go in hold
on let me look this up drunk tank is it
a prison yep a large prison cell for the
detention of drunks bang bang well you
know who you ain't you know you ain't
taking care of is a my boy Jack who's
got 75 day sober but let's hear more
Matt to my chest who relieved my
coworker and my co-workers telling me
that she had a gentleman there earlier
who was obviously
intoxicated saying that he was in the
Mafia he's in traveling around the
country state state he's been killing
people hmm
so she said she had a man there that was
a self-proclaimed serial killer but dude
that you know what I already I'm like do
they do the good killers say they're
killers yeah it seemed like if you real
good at something you more low-key about
it especially if it is you know ending
other people's existences but that's
just me
this year month now and he's been
getting away with it and he's telling
this to my coworker he is well over the
limit he's about two or three times over
the limit at this point and she's like
an older woman you know she's
defenseless basically and she's like I
will come back here and find you if you
tell anybody she goes damn it's just
making me mildly erect dude I'm not even
joking I was starting to feel a little
bit of thump done in my dump let's hear
more she goes oh no big deal I'm not a
cop
you know I'm not gonna tell anyone well
I come into work and of course she tells
me this I'm like oh you've been talking
to a serial killer for a couple hours
that's great
you know and that's the thing every time
a woman feels like they're about to get
serial killed who do they come to men
okay you know everybody wants equal
opportunity but nobody wants to deal
with serial killers themselves we look
if you want to help us then help us at
all times don't just come around ladies
when you want defense from possible
future murder of yourself
by someone else by a serial killer help
us at all times or be friends always
let's hear more that's just part of the
job a couple hours later because this
guy was released to a silver party he
comes back so you released an assumed
serial killer this is this is all over
the place more the police bring him back
for going to another bar and getting
rowdy again so I have to talk to this
serial killer allegedly he seems like a
normal dude you know so he's brought
into it that's their trick he
he ain't gonna talk to you and be
juggling knives you know and hide and
sighin
you know and you know have a cyanide
recipe on his jacket that's their trick
Matthew is that they don't you're not
supposed to know their serial killers
that's what I'm thinking man if I'm
drunk in a place and there's a there's a
lady there and she's the guard or
whatever [ __ ] yeah I'm a teller I'm a
serial killer what else you gonna do
you're bored probably you used to be in
at the bar having fun more from a police
vehicle and then there's another cop car
behind him is backup so I this guy he's
been drinking more he's actually like so
over the limit I have to sent him to the
hospital so I sent him to the hospital I
asked one of the officers to stay back
so I can talk to him and I tell him what
my coworker told me he's been going
around the country he's been killing
people and I told him that you know he
would come back and harm us if he found
out so the cops at all just look into
his criminal history and you know we'll
see where it goes from there so once I
go back inside I realize how much of a
[ __ ] idiot
I am now I'm so paranoid I I'm having
trouble sleeping I'm looking at the
security camera I'm at work right now
I'm looking at the cameras I'm seeing
this car going up and down the street
this red Jeep I've been seeing it all
night do and I don't know what the [ __ ]
to do look I'll tell you what to do man
get your life up okay you out here you
know I love you brother but listen you
first of all you said a senior citizen
lady okay and I respect senior citizens
but a lot of them you know they're just
starting to bother everybody and a
senior citizen lady told you that
there's a killer she met a killer you
know and all first of all all women say
that I'm dating this guy he seems like
he could be a serial killer that's half
the dudes out there we had a guy called
up last week [ __ ] might have killed a
lady and try to use our episode as an
alibi said he took a lady out she got
wasted he hasn't seen her in two days or
heard from her he has her phone and some
other [ __ ] uh dude I'm dumb and I know
that that is palpable
probably murder so look man you telling
me
then you scared you got the lady drunk
the man's drinking more you let the dude
go out to drink more and now you're
trying to square off with him and talk
to him
bra that do might be a murderer let him
sober up and see what he can do y'all
trying to take you guys are hanging back
and tailing a drunk how hard is it The
Dude's three times over the legal limit
he's in a red Jeep doing going we're
just going back and forth and reverse
and a parking spot that dudes [ __ ] up
do we have any knives on him
frist that [ __ ] frisk him dude
check him check his ass four blades do
what's going on you know if you are I
couldn't so if you were an officer or
not Matt but look ya'll shooting people
out there shoot this dude shoot him he
doesn't seem like he'll even care but
good luck out there dude if you don't
get murdered call us back in two months
and just just leave one voicemail says
hey it's Matt I didn't get murdered but
be good to yourself man I'm sorry to get
savage with you there but I haven't
eaten you don't only have one freakin
little thing out of a damn machine let's
hear more Casey you know it's Molly
Martin from New Albany Indiana
Oh Molly Martin you sound chipper ooh it
sound like both your parents were worked
at the you know maybe at the Brookstone
and they're extremely excited about
something it's like both your parents
were Hogwarts fans because you sound
fired up thank you for calling Molly
let's hear more I'm gonna just get that
out of the way but I don't know if you
know our New Albany is but I'm about ten
minutes from Louisville Kentucky
Louisville is where my dude I met a
friend in the middle of the night and
took him to a party and he stole
everybody's [ __ ] homework and that's
right that's I pronounce it Louisville
but laying the Bourbon anyway my mom is
a feisty five-year-old named Jackie
takes after his mama damn you a mother
to an icy five-year-old jack sound I see
is jack 75 days sober though because he
if he is he just called in and he just
said that for about one twelfth of his
life he's been using her
11:12 but for one twelfth of his life
he's sober so hopefully it's not the
same ohm word
I'm a full time college student getting
in advertising degree and I work two
jobs I'm a new listener to the podcast
and I just want to say thank you I'm
loving the laughs that you bring to my
days of hustling I got to make a comment
on your voice that voice though I got to
say you got to start offering protection
for your female listeners I've gotten
pregnant about five times listening to
you you know it's springtime and you've
got that kind of voice that makes a
woman ovulate damn boy I got that I'm
that I've you later Gator you know and
I'm out here snapping out these sounds
huh oh man I'm glad that you uh I mean
the ovulation part that's wild you know
cuz I don't really only want to google
that but you know I appreciate the
compliment and you sound like a fun lady
and I betcha little jack is excited to
have you know he's gonna probably have a
fun life because you like to have fun
and you show up everyday to feel some
joy and he I bet he'll enjoy that let's
hear a little bit more anyway thanks for
the good work and keep it up Thank You
Molly she's a new listener because
sometimes we just want to know who's
listening and so we got that that single
mother or two out there in Indiana and
dang that's that's rough out there out
in Indiana you know and it's rough
everywhere but it can be hectic out
there so take care of yourself and stay
close to your family out there thanks
for calling Molly alright guys and now
so I'm gonna make a call man I'm gonna
call Mickey and some of y'all know
trickling Mickey man he's that you know
he called in probably nine months ago
and we've had a you know a relationship
since then communication and I saw him
in Tacoma and he has cystic fibrosis in
his lungs and that's I know cystic
fibrosis sounds like a bread you would
get at Panera but it's not it's a danger
to your lungs and it basically makes
your lungs have danger in them and he
Hey and he and he has that but I met him
out in Tacoma while back when I was
doing shows there and so I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna hit up Mickey
right now and get him on the line and
and we'll go from there
today's been kind of a crazy episode but
you know what sometimes they're crazy
episodes and I'm just grateful for that
you guys showed up and I'm trying to
[ __ ] keep my brain up and let's get
Mickey on the line right now
hello big Mick hey what's up via how you
doing I'm doing good man I'm doing good
it's good to hear your voice man you
sound uh you sound like you got them
trumpets rolling man are you feeling
okay today yeah absolutely
I'm I'm living life man out of still one
to ten man I'm living out about an eight
point five right now feel life is good
that's beautiful man and but now I seen
some stuff when your Instagram is stuff
that you've been in the hospital I know
like we kind of texted a little bit
about it the last I saw you you you know
you were in Tacoma you were doing good I
know you're on the transplant list what
like what would happen man it's so crazy
feel man I'll try to keep it simple a
short but you know man
where I'm at with my lung with cystic
fibrosis the disease I have at end-stage
things can go down very quickly
and that is exactly what happened man I
ended up not to get too graphic I had up
coughing up a lot of blood man and what
happened was the the scare was that I
wasn't gonna be able to do it myself it
clawed up so basically I had to get into
the ICU man and and I went through a
very life-changing event man and if I'm
really frank and I don't mean to pull on
any any heartstrings here but yeah man I
mean my family I am we really didn't
know if I was gonna make it or not man
and I since been out of a hospital for
about a week and a half long mm-hmm and
it's just changed my perspectives man
I'm really I'm thankful for it all and
you know what I'm on the upswing man and
I am on the transplant list and any day
now those lungs are becoming in there no
way really
yeah and a lot huge huge experience in
my life man really widened even my own
perspective yeah because it seemed like
I mean you've had such a history with
this disease and you know with this
ailment anyway and you know and you
seemed like you know you had kind of
this perspective on it that was you
this is you know I'm navigating my life
with this and you know everything is not
always rosy and there's a lot of reality
and you know sometimes it can be kind of
dark and then I guess this experience
you know seems like it's really kind of
almost lifted your spirits even though
it seemed like it was such a Dao like a
such a like a dour moment you are
absolutely correct then you hit the nail
on the head man if you will never when
we caught up there Tacoma dude I had
mentioned to you a lot about that one of
the hardest parts about this is that
isolation I feel that misunderstanding
and and almost a missed connection
between my fellow man whether it was a
friendless family strangers whoever and
after this event Co dude I mean I've
never felt so loved it's so crazy that
such a traumatic and tragic experience
on the other side of the coin then it
brings people together that's what I've
learned to it to another level and for
me
yeah even even being out of it here for
the past ten days or so I like I said I
guess maybe I'm riding off that high I
don't know but i I've never felt more
loved and I I'm physically weaker than I
used to be uh but I've never been in a
better more clear space mentally and
emotionally in there man that's
fascinating man I mean yeah you're like
a fireplace bro it's like you know you
bring people you know you bring you I
mean in a weird way you're bringing
people together in a weird way yes
because yeah this is just such a
turnaround because yeah I remember you
saying like you know people don't get
that
you know people worry about the smallest
mundane things and Here I am like you
know I'm just you know I just want to be
well and I don't even know how long I
have to live and you you know and
somebody else is worried about their
[ __ ] phone plan and it's like you
know don't you realize that like there's
real you know that things are more real
and then right man right and here you
are it's kind of and here you are you
had to get so sick it's I mean it's
crazy like you got sicker but it made
you more well
yeah yes yeah absolutely badass like I
said I think that maybe I was just
hanging out with one of my best friends
today and then he he was through it with
me he goes man I was so scared that
after everything that you were just
going to be even your mindset was gonna
be even more limited Wow
and it you know what the other direction
if anything why and yes you're
completely right you know man I I can't
tell you I think I'll say this deal
mm-hmm what I learned that if you want
to live if you're a person that wants to
live and you go through an experience of
near-death and you you know I told our
we texted and I was breathing through a
tube man and uh twice and in and out of
sedation and you know really not knowing
if I was going to be there but as I got
better every day it was that experience
that I can pull from where it's like hey
you know what
there's a lower than everything that
we've got man there's a lower and for
Milo it could be me being bedridden and
breathing out of a tube and maybe the
loads of that is someone who's not even
you know conscious right you know I'm
saying there's always a lower and I
think anytime that I hit that now I'm
walking around and I'm with friends and
I'm you know talking with you man and
sharing my thoughts sharing my
experiences whatever man connecting the
people live in life dude that's that's
life and I'm more than happy to be doing
it well why wouldn't you you know what I
mean
and you are right man you know whether
it's someone else's you know we're upset
about a phone plan or you know maybe
traffic whatever it is yes I have
learned to cut the kind of the small
stuff because of my patience and
resilience and whatever words you want
to put on it that said I will always be
able to synthesize of course man we got
a problem there's also another way to
look at it to realize hey man there's a
lower to this and just be cognizant of
that and into to see the beauty in that
anyway
yeah man is powerful is powerful stuff
no you're not
look you're not man I mean you know
you're walking in the woods and I want
to you know I want to hear about the
trees you know like I want to know what
you know because I'm not on this journey
and you don't the craziest thing is man
as you're talking about some of this
I'm almost in a weird way envious
because you're like you know you're out
there Neil Armstrong and on the cusp of
existence of being alive or not alive
and I'm here in a weird way you know I'm
sitting in a place right now in a body
that is you know presumedly you know
healthy if you checked my levels and you
know you know I've eaten today and I'm
you know I'm okay I'm okay today you
know physically and I know that there's
there's probably very little risk unless
severe tragedy happens that something is
going to happen to me today or this week
you know but you're on the [ __ ] you know
you out there you know you're out there
and it's almost in a weird way I'm a
little bit envious because you get to
have those feelings that come along with
that and feelings that are backed by
real [ __ ] you know like real you know
about being alive as we talked about man
before video dude humanity and
connection is a is a very massive I
guess you could say theme in my life
that I appreciate very much and I
appreciate what you're saying yeah and I
even seal even right now as we speak
I could bleed out again that's the
negative side right like as we're
talking or you know what could also
happen though film is I could get a call
from the hospital say hey Nicky we got
lost
damn and in your right man yes I do live
a crazy
yin-yang too you know it should I stay
or should I go and you're right dude it
does it does grant that perspective in
it and it does kind of if you're able to
because sometimes I'm not man you said
it best man
sometimes you don't show up and it's
hard we can't all
do that but if you can do it 80/20 you
can do ninety ten and if you can work
every day in my opinion to try to just
be there's a slight tiny little bit
better then you wear the next day okay
man the very least you can live life
knowing that and and I think that's what
does grant me a little bit of awareness
a little bit of insight and yeah some
happiness and license its fulfillment
first-rate
yeah man you're a Magellan are out there
spelunking on exit you know you don't
through the frickin through the through
the through the caves of existence man I
mean you know that's just it's
fascinating man and I appreciate you've
been able to have like a perspective on
it that you know and I'm sure it's come
with time and an ownership of you know
living with your ailment and having a
battle cystic fibrosis but at least
being able to look or you know and have
a perspective of you know if things you
know get worse or if things get better
if I live or if I die and still being
able to speak on that it's it's it's
fascinating man I mean it uh you know
it's funny you make me think like you
know to just call somebody and tell him
that I love him you know that's what I
was thinking about about thirty seconds
ago
I would I would that's so funny you say
that man what I'm gonna talk quick like
ten-second that off you're good man you
might die but this is look man put it
out there you know what I'm saying there
this is give you 30 seconds
you taught me man you you taught me
exactly what you just said I saw you on
another podcast you got it you've got a
call from Joey Diaz and and you
explained you said man sometimes you
explain to Bobby you said uh sometimes
Joey just calls me every two weeks and
you just just to check up on me yeah you
know what I did feel right after I've
heard that ah you know what I'm gonna
send you a screenshot of this one I'll
text you a little bit later today
hmm I have after you said that I wrote
down a list of people that are near and
dear to my heart and I said it's got a
little padding on it every two weeks
hmm
call these people Tony love them ya know
but you're right man and I would
encourage you to do that
absolutely I know I know your time is
very times limited but at the same time
man those little times that we can get
to just express our love that you do so
well man you know it's it's just so
pertinent man it's so it's so massive in
our lives it's pertinent oh yeah man -
good word man you know you know it's uh
it's it's unbelievable when people show
you that they care somehow how it makes
us feel and you know what you say you
know we have let you know like I have as
much you know I got a I could spend so
much more my day letting people know I
care the thing that gets me a lot of
times is my attitude or the voice in my
head that will make other things more
important you know and I hate I'd just I
hate that but I guess that's what you
know that's one of the trials of some of
our lives you know is I mean it's a
blessing I guess that that's my Milo
right now you know my Milo is that I'm
gonna be in a bad mood right no no huh
what a but I mean it's a and if you look
at what your lo mean just to think
you're laying there you know you're
breathing through a tube and they got a
dude who just flatlined next to and
you're like Dan that guy that guy's
really scraped my bottom of the bowl I
see you you know what feel I have a
pretty good relationship with my doctors
I try to get him on my side really quick
try to be a beloved person and I asked
him straight up I said man can he be
can't did with me I'm in the ICU I've
been here for one week hmm how long did
how long do people normally last you hey
just to be straight up and and they gave
me a diplomatic answer but I knew man
and not to be more than in any sense but
I knew just like you're saying that
while I'm in there doing that people are
passing away
hmm and not only that but I was I'm one
of a handful hundreds of people in the
whether it's the country or in the world
that is going through this you know it
and I gets beat really quick but I guess
all I'm trying to get at is once again
how we can use this to benefit ourselves
and our lives just to realizing and then
just to just appreciate things and try
to just slow down stop us know the road
is for a second just love love lightly
for sure not in a platitude sense right
not in like oh they're free little bit
but really actually try to do it yeah
yeah I was having a good day the other
day and I was texting a friend and he
said man if you could do me a favor
right now he said just stop and just
breathe just be grateful for whatever
good things are happening you know
whatever you know whatever it is respond
to my moment to be grateful for it and
then you know it just it put it in
perspective because it's like it's so
weird man when things aren't going good
how we'll hope they're going good and
then when they're going good we forget
to be grateful sometimes that they are
but man it's just you know and I'll tell
you this man I know whenever you know we
met up in Tacoma and I know you know you
had we wanted you to get up on stage and
we're still packaging that together and
and I think I'm gonna put a whole little
episode together here even you know
including some of that and and some of
this call to I think um
you know and you know we want you to get
on stage and then you got sick and I
just really hope that I'm not
blacklisted that the old I can't make it
cuz I might not be alive trick we've
heard that before guy we've heard that
before guy dude you know what's funny is
um you know whenever I saw you in person
whenever we met up in person you you
reminded me a little bit of my sister in
a weird way and my sister is on the
transplant list you know my sister got a
transplant for a liver transplant yeah
back in the day
and there was just some things like I
don't know if this is there's like you
guys almost I don't know if you you
didn't you looked a little bit the same
in a strange way and I don't know if
there's like because I don't know I mean
you know it was just kind of and it just
suddenly made me it took me back to you
know who she was a little bit and it it
like made it so much more real to me you
know it reminded me I don't know it's
like I look at my sister a lot of times
and I'll put all these other things on
her like oh she's my sister and she
doesn't you know follow through on these
things and she'll say she gonna mail me
something and been [ __ ] nine years and
that [ __ ] ain't mailing [ __ ] and all
you know you know I'll start stacking up
these you know resentments and little
things that go with being brother and
sister but then it put me I forget that
she you know had this thing in her life
and then it was like the biggest thing
of our whole childhood was her being
sick and I mean she was you know she was
jaundice colored I mean she was a yellow
child she was great you know green or
yellow most of my youth I had a friend
who had this he had cystic fibrosis and
that he was always great yeah yeah man
you got a green friend that's [ __ ]
that's next-level bro you you got a
green on st. Patrick's Day dude I would
take that [ __ ] around the block you
feel me
but but it just put you know what it
made it so much more real to me you know
it made it like man like it made me
remember this thing about my sister and
it made me I mean I guess it made me
feel a little bit bad that I hadn't I
don't know checked in with her about
seeing what was going on about that or
but it made it's you and made me relate
it just put a lot of pieces together
because there was something I could
connect to you know yes it's an energy
thing not to be a seriousiy but do you
think that it's maybe just some sort of
almost like a wavelength or just a vibe
that you know maybe
relateable that I had to show what do
you think um
what that when I saw you it made me
think of her yeah I think it just made
me for one I probably felt sorry for
myself I felt a little bit sorry that I
hadn't checked in with her about this
you know her you know the rejection
medicine and all those types of things
that she has to take and the extra thing
she has to do and you know the fears
this in just the fears that she may
think about sometimes that you know made
me kind of feel I guess I mean as
selfish it isn't may feel a bit sorry
for myself you know sorry that I hadn't
done those things or disappointed in
myself but then it made me I don't know
there was like a laugh or something
you know because you you know you don't
I would say if if someone looks on a
scale of 1 to 10 and 10 is super healthy
you know you probably looked at like uh
you know a seven you probably one of the
best looking [ __ ] sick dudes I've
ever seen straight up my damn dude this
dude could be a [ __ ] model up in a
you know in a in the transplant ward
this dude's gonna be doing [ __ ] photo
shoots in the hallway you know but but
it may but there was like a there was
some sickness there you can see you know
ye you can feel a little bit you know
you're breathing you said is it what
percentage of brief was your breathing
at whenever I saw you oh man yeah I
think we saw Muse at 19 and Allison like
17 percent so the way I try to describe
that I think if you remember I say you
know feel man oh wait you're left low
cut your right lung in half and I got
less than that damn why Mickey were
rolling on a sandwich sack full of air
bro you coming in late a.m. bruh and so
look I think there was some some
sickness there I guess a little bit that
you can you know but your spirit isn't
sick though it's like this shell that
you're in had to has some a you know a
little sickness you say your weight was
low so you know you you know you don't
look like you know Adonis you know it's
not like you're looking like you know
Schwarzenegger at 19 years old
right right so so but what your spirit
was at a [ __ ] 30 you know like or
just you know your that you the look in
somebody's eyes is so much more alive
when their body is sick do you know what
I'm talking about oh yes absolutely yeah
what is any know it said what is that ah
dude it it's hard so now we're getting
to those points where it's really
difficult to articulate and put into
words right hmm but I think if I had to
try to it really does get to that scene
that we've been talking about of whether
it's humanity whether its perspective
all these Tyson's words that we want to
use on I think that you don't want to
try bit like this feel man we like to
think that you know you ever hear
something
I just just keep fighting keep fighting
he's a fighter she's a fighter and we
kind of think about that in a sense of
like maybe when they're sedated maybe
when their eyes are closed and when
you're not able to talk to us but what I
realized man is that you know even when
I saw you right now maybe even within
the past five years I've been fighting
this is the fight right now man it
doesn't it didn't stop again to begin
it's kind of just always been yeah and
you know yes you probably got to fight a
little bit harder during those very
critical times and maybe that's what you
see man who knows that like maybe it's
something for the lives that this person
who just lives a life where they're
constantly challenged and they've got to
have a resilience for them because if
they don't it was the second that they
stopped man who knows what could happen
yeah and maybe that is why there's just
a nasty there maybe there's just a life
there whatever it is and I'll be honest
man it's like we talked about there's
the other side of the coin where they'll
just get a little bit too hard and maybe
it's not there yeah and that's when
that's when we can be there as friends
and family not overwhelm and not push
but just be there is that when your
family did that kind of brought you back
around is that something that that kind
of happened this time that you know your
family kind of you know I mean yes
definitely they definitely were there's
also a lot of struggles now I mean I'm
sure you can be sympathetic to a mother
who's seeing her son
you know breathing through a tube and
dated and just you know eyes shut
that's a good like I said two
descriptions here but blood on his neck
because of the coughing and you know
it's like it just looks really scary and
we all as human beings we all have the
ability to become emotionally
compromised right and that's gotta be so
hard to see was my mom my mom was my mom
was phenomenal to it my friends were
phenomenal and that's my caregiving team
you know that's not hey huh
they're just uplifting me in every
single way man and and I'm so fortunate
and like I said yes going harking back
to that that's why I felt that was amen
you know and I realized you know that
like you know what these people don't
need to fully understand what I what I
want them to you if they're just you say
so in times if they just show up yeah if
they're just better whole heartedly and
just their family that's that's all you
need sometimes Wow - yeah man a great
caregiver team and my mom my dad my
brother sold out from Japan damn honest
okay yeah man it my best friend hi-yah
that's a travois why so I unfortunately
blessed to have these people man so it's
great man I love man you just saw just
you know you're making me you're making
me you know this is gonna make me get
out of bed tomorrow man cuz just show up
because if I get up and I get going
though you don't know also what guy
or what a higher power once what I might
be the tool I might be the wrench
tomorrow that God needs to show somebody
else somehow that you know that their
day is gonna be a little bit okay and
not in a selfish way but just in a tool
way like I might be somebody else can't
fit it right and I may be you know I
might be the screwdriver for a second
you know see oh man I'm wholeheartedly
believe that uh you know I'm not sure
sure I called you when I was in that and
that I called the hotline my messages
man it was a with the dark one and I
know you're darker than you can't I feel
my pain in my voice mm-hmm
and yeah man I'm a whole whole heart of
believing and what you do who you are as
I told you man is your example of the
person manic and I'll just tell you man
like I did and if you can hear someone
listening I'm I'm proud to I'm just I'm
just [ __ ] proud man to call you
someone that supports me and if I dare
throw that stable F word around now I've
gotta call you the prince I really am
well so please keep doing what you doing
now make it great
I love it man and you inspire people to
be better people are treated anything
well I just want to be a better person
myself man and and you inspire me dude
100% I you know I needed so glad we got
to connect today because I needed to
hear a lot of this stuff man you know
something's wrong with me I need to be
constantly reminded in order to stay in
a good direction
there's just something you know I'm a
fry I'm a last minute I have a last
minute memory and I just have to be
reminded constantly one last question
before you go do when you get to some of
those moments and you know you're riding
that cusp of like am I gonna be okay how
long am I gonna live you know you know
because the fear sure it might not sound
the people super real as we're talking
about it but when you're laying in a
hospital ward or you're laying in a bed
and your family's around you're like
[ __ ] I mean there's not many you know
the next time they could be standing
around me could be I'm in a coffin or
I'm in a you know at a wake or something
you know I mean there's not there's only
too many reasons you know the family's
gay
then around your bed you know if you're
doing like some special jerking off or
something a circus family or if you're
sick and do you but do you feel any
different connection as you get out
there to like a higher power or
something in the universe and you don't
have to look man don't you know you do
you feel anything or is it all just feel
human did you have any any experience
with any of that I'll say this man first
of all most you know I I was raised in a
Catholic school man and in her all
honesty that kind of I went through kc8
you know almost nearly 10 years to do
that in my my family is very uh good
Catholic you know and actually I kind of
took the other way to it back in the day
mm-hmm I can tell you this every what I
mean by that is you know I was a little
bit college and I really know about
maybe a dogmatic religion but I won't
say this man uh in my adult years I do
believe you know I I don't know how to
explain it I think these are things that
if we could we'd we'd know the secrets
of the world yeah that yeah man I feel
like there's a synchronicity dude I feel
like you know maybe not the
quote-unquote everything happens for a
reason but more or less that we if we
express ourselves in the way and just
Col heartedly and authentically that I
think over time you're just going to
bring the right people in your life well
that said man I was told this vo
that when word got around from my
friends and family that I was in ICU my
name got placed in a lot of prayer
circles and people were praying for me
my mom told me every day and I'll be
really honest with you at that time I
kind of I don't want that I've rolled my
eyes but I was kind of like you know mom
I'm glad that that helps you but that
does nothing for me I didn't feel it we
talked about I didn't steal yeah but
I'll say this man I mean my my song I'm
singing a different tune of these days
because sometimes I think about it and
like
how do I not how do i I don't know
you know and I've also had a lot of
people tell me recently that I've just
reconnected with due to this experience
that uh you know nicking that I I was
thinking about you a couple weeks ago
ran and I wonder like where that it stem
from you know and I build this excuse me
this this theory that uh you know maybe
the more that we are in other people's
minds just you know maybe there's
something there there's a synchronous
year there's a love maybe there is some
sort of higher power to yeah and you
know I don't know what comes after
obviously yeah after life and whatnot
but I will say that you know we had
mentioned humanity I think that's a
massive part of it but you know that
that maybe that we're in people's lives
for a reason yeah we never know what man
we never know and but we you know just
just be a part of that and I think it's
I think it's a good thing for sure is it
was it scary when you get that close to
like dying like is this scary you're
like what is it like Mannix
I think you know from I can only tell
from my experience but it was such a
survival aspect man you know not to go
crazy but dude I saw such attractive
nurses man oh my good yeah yeah who's
the most beautiful caring women and men
but but you know particularly the winner
from yeah women first do men's second oh
man yeah me too man for v2 but damn and
I know yeah you are I'd know I need to
have really a want to and you got a tube
in your throat
you probably think you're gay he's
laying there with a two of idiot wrote
they're probably like goddess didn't
know I could only write I have to go are
you and the first thing I said when she
pulled that to Jones out of my cell I
told I said I really apologize about
that he got you a beautiful I guess I
got a know these things but yeah then
again
it really is just much about I didn't
have a fear man what I get fearful of
was out I was noticing these
perspectives that that I was building in
my head rump leg man I never thought
about life like this and when I got
fearful others you know I'm kind of
crazy man but I look at like this I was
like dude I feel like I'm getting closer
to the truth mmm and and what I mean by
that honestly feel dude it like I said
I'm a sound off the wall here but I
really I think that the closer you get
to the truth whatever that means the
closer and closer you get to it man when
you figure it all out that's when you're
gone hmm and uh and if you like that
what crazy though is that that's who did
a beautiful thing and you can share it
with people and that's that's what I
like to do mmm
man I you know I just feel this 100%
thanks so much for your time dude
and so you could get a call any day and
get those hitters huh yes any day dude
I'm looking forward to it dude and okay
you know seeing you again I'm gonna take
a flight i'ma go first thing I'll do
well but they could slide out to the
College for Washington Comedy look a
week or so just enjoy lighten it well
look man I'll say this do we have a
patreon here and uh and you know I think
we got enough money in the account bro
whenever you get them new hitters dude
we'll get you down here get you on an
episode yeah well I want to talk more
about this kind of stuff in studio and
get you on an episode and get you over
to the store and uh you know and they
got some real you know straight gutter
chicks and dudes over there we could
probably introduce you to as well thanks
will do great thanks man well you know
what it is it's the real there's a real
callers to the podcast except for the
the Bobby Lee when his girlfriend you
know we I wanted to get a woman as well
so
I was talking her about the show and I
was like Bobby definitely has problems
and she goes oh she goes well I'll call
him with some problems of Bobby's but
the other two were real calls man and so
it's just crazy you know it's so awesome
man it's so awesome
you know there's one jump that he said
there's this one instance you had with I
think his name is Max besides were in
the bar you said hello to this woman and
you said I have adult asthma yeah and
she was like oh okay you know you're
always just trying to make sure if we
can relate on certain ailments that we
had right and uh I thought about that I
was like Nana I feel like I indirect me
you might have man you might have been a
writer and you didn't even know it bro
[Laughter]
again man I'm proud of you dude and like
I said I just thank you very much for
calling man it means a lot for me as
well we're each other's strength in this
way man well I want to apologize to man
I feel like I probably could have been a
little bit more on the ball and keeping
in touch over the past couple past month
you know and so you know I hope you
forgive me for that man oh no worries
man it never never was about that so hey
man like I said how do you dude thank
you very much for calling man and
anytime anytime did you know yeah man
well Allah I'll be keeping in touch dude
and thank you so much for your time
today man send me a couple of pics of
you in the hospital I'll pull some off
the Instagram so if we package this up
that um you know that we can get this
out there dude I meet us thank you so
much man I just really appreciate your
time today man
of course you know man I learned my last
ex I'm happy to be a part of it yeah
100% man ohm word bruh be good Mickey
I'll talk to you soon I feel you take
care man all right you too brother you
know having him call and spend time when
I don't even know how much time and he
don't even know how much what his time
is like you know when I saw him in
person he he looks a lot younger because
his body is not
holding on as much way to muscle you
know he because your body's your body
ain't concerned about that about
cosmetic stuff your body ain't you know
think about L'Oreal and Estee Lauder
your body's thinking about why just need
to be I need to you know take care of
what's going on inside imma spend my
energy there and so he looks like 20 or
something but he's 28 I think or maybe I
don't even know he's an adult you know
but he's not 20 but he looks so young he
looks maybe even 17 or 18 but I didn't
know him when he was well you know I
only known him when he had this illness
and I don't know I don't know I'm trying
to say I just got a lot of my mind I
guess you know I feel [ __ ] kind of
filled up that's crazy
you know I wasn't even expecting to
really get into all that kind of stuff
today and then here we here we did but
that's life that's life you know you
don't know what you're gonna get into
you don't know you know you don't know
and then you show up and then life says
out here here's here's what you could
get into today you know here's somebody
maybe you can help today you know
there's always a lower low if you take
anything out of that call right there
that's what I'm takin you know I'm
sitting here thinking I'll tell you
right now the things I'm in fear of
right now in my life I'm in fear that
people are gonna think that I'm not that
I'm not a good person
that's one of my biggest ones always
ever since I was a child or something
happened I don't know but I feel like
even if I care about somebody that
they're not gonna believe it and they're
gonna think I'm a fraud and so then I
get afraid to care and then it just that
whole thing metastasizes and you know
that's a bad little cyclone for me
you know I'm um I'm more you know the
things I'm worried about I got a little
dent on the back of my car from an
accident a while back
worried about that that thing keeps
popping in my [ __ ] head you know what
I'm worried about I'm worried about uh
you know I'm worried about I haven't you
know being one of the gym or taking good
care of myself physically you know maybe
I don't look 100% the way that I want to
look those are things that I'm worried
about
those are my worries right now I mean
I'm worried about some other people too
I'm worried about my sister you know I
want her to be happy and I want her to
be well and you know she's getting
healthier out there in her life right
now and that's you know I'm worried
about her I'm worried about my mother
you know she hurt her hip last week and
something about her you know there's
some other other people I'm worried
about I'm worried about some of my
friends in a a program I'm worried about
you know those things stuff like that
but man when you look at that when I
look at that when I take that those
bunch of little worries and fears or you
know man I'm doing okay I'm doing okay
somebody out there don't have it
somebody out there laying in a coma
flirtin with the Lord right now and
their families around them thinking
about him and wishing for him I'm doing
okay so I don't mean to bring people
into that depth right now and butt-fuck
I don't know I don't know if I'm gonna
put this on today's episode you know
this call I came in and did this call in
advance how I was gonna do a follow-up
but I might make this the [ __ ]
episode today I don't know if it's not
if it is because I haven't even done the
episode yet so if I'm this might not
even make sense but I haven't taped
today's episode yet
I'm about to do that next but I might
just tape a beginning and just put this
whole Mickey call on because uh what am
I gonna do I'm gonna take this moment
this real moment here and I had and
shelve it you know for when it's
comfortable you know or later
is there a when is the later
do I know you know what if Mitt you know
the dudes on a transplant list and he
just got expedited up the list
look when I saw him two months ago six
weeks ago he wasn't at the top of the
list and he said it could be any day now
he gets him new hitters get in there it
could be any day boy Mickey coming in
with him hot [ __ ] you know airbags
that dude cuz that dude's Runnels
[ __ ] small Ziploc them little baby
ones right now you might put half a
sandwich in you ever get that [ __ ] you
had lunch you open your sack and you get
that [ __ ] little hat Ziploc started
making them damn there's angry mother
sacks that's what I call them you ever
get that little hitter from your mother
you got half a sandwich in that [ __ ] or
that's the kind of that's that's when
your step daddy made you lunch you know
that you get any you open your lunch
sack and it feels kind of heavy you're
thinking oh I got this new step daddy
you know he gonna treat me right with
that brown bread with that brown bag
hitter and then you and you little so
it's a you know opening that brown bag
when you little at lunch at set the
school house you crackin under that
thing it takes you a second you got to
unfold it and you got to read the side
you know with something [ __ ]
have a good day love you know mr. Tim or
whatever his name is you know mr. Darryl
whoever your new step daddy isn't you
like all he may mean this thing you know
and you reach down in that sack and you
got to put your arm you got a little arm
you got to put that [ __ ] almost all the
way in that lunch sack and you get in
there and you pull out that sandwich and
it's one of those little half things
because Ziploc started making little
ones and he made half a sandwich and put
it in that thing and it's it's not even
a unique you know and you're like this
supposed to be for just some jelly beans
or something and stepdaddy's sandwich
day that stepdaddy's sandwich day and
that is a sin and and that is a sin but
those are the air bags that Mickey's
running on them half hitters man
and it's crazy that a little bit of air
left in his lungs and he is thinking
about that there's somebody worse off
than him
[ __ ] look bro if that ain't the it look
what else am I going to talk about today
we had some calls that came in maybe I
got to some of those first or maybe I
got to some of those second I don't know
I might this might be the whole episode
this might be the end this may be the
beginning I'm not sure but if this was
today's episode man I don't what else do
I need to get through the week what else
do you need if you have any thoughts on
today's episode hit the hotline man nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three as well we're still taking calls
for Greyhound we're going to do an
expose number two you know I want to
thank gray block Pete's as always I want
to thank whatever higher power out there
my god whatever they keeps me alive so
that maybe I can wake up tomorrow and
not think about all what's gonna happen
to me today but how can I be a part of
something to happen to somebody else
because if I don't do that then what the
[ __ ] am i doing you know what the [ __ ]
am i doing if I'm not doing that because
goddamn you know what I you know what is
my biggest sickness if I look back on my
life is worrying about me
you know worrying about me and maybe
next week I'll be infected by myself
again but right now today for this
moment I'm gonna try not to be
and that's trickling Micky man damn [ __ ]
dude almost out of lungs but god damn
how many hearts does he have thank you
guys for being here with me man I'm
gonna try and pipe out you know I'm a
Piper celebrating right now because this
is sometimes it fits and sometimes it
doesn't and I'll be damned if it don't
fit right
[Music]
hit that hotline guys we have any
thoughts we might do a follow-up on the
Mickey episode
we'll do that old fashioned to follow up
if you've had an experience
[Music]
well you've been close to the edge I
know it's you I don't know man whatever
if you think Mickey's out of his mom
maybe don't have enough air in his brain
and whatever you think
you get that hot line man
because I'm out here feeling bro you
need me I'll be in my field have some
fun while we all die be good yourself
[Music]